поїхали е Доброго дня шановні колеги
раді всіх вас вітати на нашому вебінарі
в рамках проекту пагосте формування
нових механізмів управління на основі
партнерства та стандартизації підготовки
викладачів професійної освіти в Україні
Дякуємо нашим партнерам за активну
участь в організації цього вебінару
закладам освіти які е є У цьому проекті
і ведуть його понад три роки маємо вже
певні досягнення і готові з вами
поділитися у нашому вебінарі зараз для
участі в нашому вебінарі зареєструвалося
понад 200 учасників це заклади вищої
фахової передвищої та
професійно-технічної освіти і для
привітального слова запрошую Ірину шумік
генерального директора директорату
професійної освіти
мо Добрий день шановні колеги
надзвичайно рада всіх бачити і перш за
все хочу подякувати своїм колегам з
якими ми дійсно більше ніж три роки рука
обруку йшли для того щоб презентувати
сьогодні ті напрацювання які вдалося
досягнути І власне поділитися нашим
досвідом покращення
комунікації сьогодні повертаюся в
Україну і радію від того що отримала
нові знання на Європейському форумі який
проводився по професійній досконалості і
хочу сказати що дійсно для всіх для всіх
абсолютно європейських країн сьогодні
найголовніше питання - це налагодження
комунікації налагодження комунікації з
користувачами налагодження комунікації
зі студентами з роботодавцями і всі
усвідомлюють Наскільки ефективна
комунікація в нашому мінливому світі
сьогодні є надзвичайно важливою
неможливо досягнути успіху без синергії
без того щоби працювати всім разом
але намагаючися власне покращити освітні
послуги І тут якраз наш
проект має відповідні напрацювання які
мені здається можуть бути використані
закладами всіх рівнів вищої хої перед
вищої професійно-технічної освіти для
того щоб наша співпраця дійсно була
ефективною я власне зародився цей проект
як з'явилася ідея ми маємо всі і ви є
користувачами або здійснюєте підготовку
за 015 спеціальністю професійна освіта і
ми помітили що на жаль випускники
закладів вищої освіти цієї спеціальності
не повертаються до закладів професійної
освіти фахової передвищої освіти на
працевлаштування і наша основна задача
була зрозуміти чому це не відбувається
де ми маємо яі прогалини і як
е покращити взагалі як підготовку таких
фахівців так і їхню подальше влаштування
я точно знаю що сьогодні будуть
презентації на колег і точно знаю що
їхні показники вони покращились після
того як вони почали застосовувати
методологію яка була напрацьована
спільно з нашими колегами з Німеччини
Італії і Австрії такий взаємообмін
кращими практиками він дійсно сприяв
тому що вдалося досягти позитивних
результатів моє особисте глибоке
переконання Якщо ми будемо чути одне
одного дослухатися і не тільки ми між
собою заклади освіта а ще тут важливу
роль відіграють і наші студенти для кого
ми працюємо або на кого ми
працюємо від цього буде залежити і
якість майбутнього людського капіталу
який все ж таки ми плануємо і робимо все
максимально можливе для того щоби
зберегти Я з вашого дозволу розпочну
презентацію Ага все ж таки спробую
зробити так щоб мене загубилось
Перепрошую трошки для сторонньої за
сторонньої
ми тому що е- сьогодні перебуваю і Щось
пішло не так зараз Ми
змінимо так одну
секундочку зараз
ще раз спробую поширити екран якщо не
вдасться то буду просити моїх колег мене
в цьому підстрахувати але все ж таки
Сподіваюся що все буде добре колеги
хтось технічний скажіть нормально чи ви
добре так окей Все тоді поїхали власне
за результатами цієї трирічної співпраці
були напрацьовані методичні рекомендації
щодо запровадження механізмів управління
на основі партнерства у закладах освіти
які здійснюють підготовку здобувачів за
спеціальністю 015 професійна
освіта Ми сьогодні от маємо такі
проміжні підсумки вступної кампанії ці
дані на сьогодні взяті з інфоресурсу і
можна пересвідчити що в тоцьму році було
зараховано на на хвилиночку та 53% від
загальної кількості здобувачів освіти
які продовжують навчатися за
спеціальністю
015 ви бачите скільки було прийнято за
різними рівнями освіти на папого
молодшого бакалавра молодшого бакалавра
бакалавра і магістра а це означає що
увага та або зацікавленість у певних
педагогіч спеціальностях навіть якщо
вони мають професійне спрямування вона
на сьогодні підвищується і це може
свідчити про те що найближчим часом ми
все ж таки отримаємо нову когорту
професіоналів наших колег
педагогів міністерством освіти і науки
було затверджено методичні рекомендації
які були напрацьовані спільно з нашими
колегами е Це була така довга
робота тривала робота довжиною майже в
рік і я ще раз хочу подякувати своїм
колегам які ее дуже відповідально
поставилися до цього процесу і своїм
колегам із директорату професійної
освіти е до того що все ж таки Нам
вдалося цей документ затвердити що ж
пропонує цей документ Ну по-перше ми
спільно шляхом емпіричним напрацювали ті
гру групи стейкхолдерів е які мають
залучатися до таких партнерств це
заклади освіти підприємства установи
організації
і також що є немало важливо Це
громадські організації ми визначили
різні форми партнерства б стейкхолдерами
тому
що ці форми вони виникли не просто так
вони виникли в рамках апропації наших
колег з університетів і я хочу сказати
що варіативність цих форм вона якраз
дозволяє дуже гнучко поставити собі і
організувати цю роботу І кожен може
обрати саме ту форму або декілька форм
зробити їхні комбінацію які дозволять
все ж таки це партнерство зробити
ефективнім Ну і ми вже так само з
досвіду рекоментували певний алгоритм
створення діяльності професійних дорачих
органів Я знаю як ми всі ставимося часто
до дорачих органів думаємо що е чим
більше в нас різних консультаційних рад
робочих груп тим гірше так ними треба
вміти упраняти але коли ми з вами
знаходимося в постійній дискусії
обговореннях це означає що ми можемо
знайти рішення які будуть найкращі і
найбільш прийнятні для всіх
стейкхолдерів яких стосується які саме
форми партнерств ми пропонуємо між
стейкхолдерами Мої колеги сьогодні
розкриють більш детально вже власні
приклади але узагальнено це безумовно
організація освітнього процесу яка
враховує особливості партнерства і
залучає всіх партнерів до цього процесу
це обов'язкове підвищення кваліфікації
або ж стажування педагогічних
працівників закладів освіти Я зараз маю
на увазі фахову передвищу і професійну
освіту у закладах вищої освіти які
провадять
ее підготовку за спеціальністю 015 зараз
це створення цих доречих органів і я в
очікуванні власне презентації від книгу
тому що знаю що Мої колеги теж входять
до складу їхнього дорачого органу і
можуть обговорити нагальні потреби і
проблеми які ми маємо на сьогодні в
е підготовці за спеціальністю 015 ми
чітко розуміємо що крім форм
обговорень різних дискусій надзвичайно
важливе ще де це відбувається і чи
освітній простір підготовки за тою чи
іншою професією або ж спеціальністю Він
сприяє він є комфортним і він якраз
надихає на нові ідеї він є креативним
тому
ее кожен із закладів намагався теж ж
створити таку певну інфраструктуру для
налагодження і здійснення в подальшому
цього партнерства підготовці здобувачів
за 015 спеціальністю і це зрозуміло що
не знаю як де А ми у професійній освіті
сповідуємо Принцип що навчання має бути
за принципом leing by doing тобто
навчатися через те безпосередньо через
практичну діяльність через практичну
роботу і от спільна реалізація
різноманітних заходів соціальних
проектів майстер-класів тренінгів вона
теж має таки дуже позитивний і показала
зарекомендувала себе як дуже
позитивний модель співпраці позитивну
модель співпраці що ж
передбачає під собою
організаціюсвітнього процесу на основі
партнерства ну перш за все це дійсно
перегляд тої нормативної бази якою ми
всі з вами керуємося в освітньому
процесі цеї програми навчальні плани
силабуси це розроблення
відповідних навчальних матеріалів і і
теж знаю як цікаво було працювати
залучалися проводилися різноманітні
тренінги від наших іноземних партнерів і
для учнів чи для студентів і для
викладачів і на сьогодні вже наші
заклади учасники якісно змінили е власне
це свій досвід Я теж думаю що вони
готові будуть вам передати І обов'язково
з ним не поділяться це залучення
педагогічних працівників закладів
професійної та передвищої освіти власне
до практичних занять з тих дисциплін які
мають професійне спрямування до
керівництва відповідно педагогічними
практиками до проведення їх атестації
підсумкового оцінювання керівництва
курсовими роботами це теж дозволяє
помінятися обмінятися певною експертизою
і почути потреби одне одного Можливо
навіть потреби директорів закладів
освіти професійної фахової передвищої е
А які навички Якими компетентностями
мають сьогодні володіти наші випускники
закладів вищої освіти які завтра вже
стануть викладачами цих
закладів Ну і звичайно як я вже говорила
третій аспект - це безумовно практична
підготовка А ми спільно з колегами
пропонуємо вам відповідні заходи до
покращення і вдосконалення процедур які
на сьогодні існують є досить
стандартними закладами вищої освіти це
певні рекомендації до проведення
атестаційного екзамену залучення
безпосередньо
холдерів до складу комісії
а проведення іспиту у різні за різними
формами в декілька етапів письмовий та
усний виконання попереднього завдання як
допуску до екзамену і звичайно
відтворення наявний знак знань і
застосування їх у типових ситуаціях
тобто такий собі кейстаді
щодо підвищення кваліфікації викладачів
закладів професійно-технічної фахово
передвищої освіти тут теж
пропонується різні варіації це може бути
Як короткострокове навчання в рамках
одного кредиту так і навіть окремі
програми Це все можна
визначати попередньо в рамках обговорень
вивчення
потреб педагогів і може бути навіть
колеги рекомендують до шести кредитів Ми
теж пропонуємо все ж таки
використовувати такий модульний принцип
побудови Таких програм які будуть
включати ми презентацію думаю теж
поділимося відповідно
соціально-гуманітарні ненятно
ня Дякую Олексію ще раз нагадую колеги
ми покращуємо свої Digital навички і
тому Слідкуйте за своїми
мікрофончиками не вмикайте їх без
потреби і власне Я повертаюся до модулів
нас що цікавить психолого-педагогічний
модуль і модуль професійного розвитку а
забезпечення якісної підготовки
здобувачів освіти Ми пропонуємо робити
також шляхом створення професійних
дорачих органів і відповідної
інфраструктури Я вже про це говорила це
можуть бути як коворкінг простори це
можуть бути хаби центри розвитку
інновацій дослідницькі лабораторії
навіть якщоце педагогічні лабораторії
або я кажу освітні хаби І власне
основна ідея або основне завдання таких
центрів -
це розвиток професійних і особистісних
компетентностей відповідно в
залученні або в співпраці співдіяльності
усіх
стейкхолдерів що стосується професійних
дорадчих органів то тут ми теж
пропонуємо до їх складу обов'яз включати
як
представників таких
найвпливовіших і найголовніших
стейкхолдерів це закладів
професійно-технічної тахово двищої
освіти також було би добре долучати до
цього
представників органів управління це
можуть бути державної влади органи
місцевого самоврядування громади Е для
того
щоб знаєте я не хочу це назвати таким
кластерним підходом але щоби було таке
громадське свідоме розуміння навіщо ми
це ро
і в нашому випадку і в нашій ситуації
покращенні іміджу роботи педагогічного
працівника воно є надзвичайно важливим
Ну і це зрозуміло що все ця діяльність
вона як правило здійснюється на
добровільних засадах ми тут нікого не
можемо примушувати але Наша задача
взагалі задача будь-якого управлінця
навіть якщо ми кажемо про рівень кафедри
чи
факультету це в
власне ой-ой-ой Я з Міжнародної
конференції to inspire
надихнути надихнути наших основних колег
і
стейкхолдерів цією ідеєю і дійсно
показати
важливість ну зрозуміло що дорчі органи
це незакони вони мають
відповідні мають відповідний
рекомендаційний характер але дослухатися
до думки іншого є надзвичайно важливо
щодо завдань профе дорачих органів це
може бути як прогнозування потреб
відповідно у викладачах професійної
освіти на тій чи іншій території або
громаді або навіть якщо ми кажемо про
екосистему закладів професійної фахової
передвищої освіти це власне пропозиції
щодо удосконалення навчальних планів і
програм це безпосередня участь в
освітньому процесі через залучення
відповідних фахівців це можливо бути
навіть менторство е там де є потреба
якісного покращення освітнього процесу
ви проходите всі через процедури
акредитації І взагалі Цей формат
останніх років акредитації показує
наскільки важливо мати відповідні
створені партнерства І як це позитивно
впливає на якість надання освітніх
послуг таце безумовно сприяння
працевлаштування випускників і я думаю
що сьогодні колеги теж поділяться Ми для
цього в рамках проекту створили окремий
ресурс до якого вас всіх активно просимо
долучитися Тому що інколи складно
проводити комунікацію з величезною
кількістю от в нас зараз вже 325
учасників а може бути ще більше от
власне для цього ми створили відповідний
онлайн-ресурс сайт який є досить зручним
в користуванні і в рамках якого ця ця
комунікація може бути значно покращено
це розвиток інфраструктури партнерств
відповідно постійний моніторинг якості
освіти Ну і як я вже теж говорила
реалізація певних спільних практик
і і
партнерств колеги я сподіваюся не
забрала дуже довго вашого часу знаю що
всі деталі всі родзинки всі секрети Яки
сьогодні будуть
розповідати наші колеги я хочу сказати
що до цього проекту були залучені
заклади вищої освіти з Києва Одеси
Харкова і ми знаємо як зараз не просто
Харкову і
Одесі постійно за вас переживаємо і я ще
раз висловлюю слова величезної поваги і
просто захоплююсь вашим прагненням що
навіть в такі моменти Я просто
періодично на зв'язку з нашими колегами
з Харкова знаю що незважаючи ні на що
бачу пані Олену і пана Романа незважаючи
ні на що ви продовжуєте ви продовжуєте
творити і ви продовжуєте дійсно
працювати над те щоб майбутнє України
було прекрасним колеги Ще раз всім
величезна подяка я передаю слово
модератору і сподіваюся що сьогоднішній
вебінар для вас буде дуже
цікавий Дуже дякую
Дякуємо так Дякуємо Ірина Володимирівна
за надихаючу промову за візуальну
презентацію методичних рекомендації які
я сподіваюсь після цього стали
зрозумілими абсолютно всім навіть тим
хто бачив це вперше і я хочу передати
слово одному з головних
драйверів вдосконалення підготовки
викладачів професійної освіти про яких
вже згадувала Ірина Володимирівна
Київський національний економічний
університет І запрошую презентувати свої
результати Світлану Цимбалюк доктора
економічних наук Київського
національного економічного
університету колеги вітаю щиро вітаю
учасників вебінару насамперед хочу
подякувати колегам з міністер мірства
освіти і науки України за організацію
цього вебінару можливості поділитися
власним досвідом і більш детальніше
вивчити досвід наших колег зараз
секундочку Поділюсь своєю презентації
скажіть колеги будь ласка вам видно мою
презентацію так чудово е Отже Тема моєї
презентації управління підготовкою
викладачів професійної освіти на засадах
партнерства у Київському Національному
економічному університеті імені Вадима
Гетьмана під час своєї презентації Я
хочу презентувати концепцію розвитку
системи підготовки викладачів
професійної освіти на основі
стандартизації та партнерства і
зупинитися на двох структурах які ми
створили запустили і зараз вони активно
працюють для реалізації затвердженої
концепції Це професійний дорачий комітет
спеціальності 05 11 професійна освіта
економіка та коворкінговий центр
економічної та бізнес-освіти Отже на
початку реалізації нашого проекту
погосте який
фінансується Європейським Союзом еразмус
програми asмус плюс нами було розроблено
затверджено та розпочато реалізацію
концепції розвитку системи підготовки
викладачів професійної освіти на основі
стандартизації та партнерства яка
спрямована на Нала гоження ефективних
механізмів партнерства з нашими
стейкхолдерами відповідно до
затвердженої нами концепції ми
запланували створити дві структури
професійний дорачий комітет І власне
досвід створення і роботи цього
професійного дорачого комітету було
покладено в основу розробки методичних
рекомендації про які згадувала наша
колега пані Ірина Шумик а також створити
коворки нговий центр економічної та
бізнес-освіти що стосується нашого
професійного дурачого комітету до до
складу комітету увійшли представники
директорату професійної освіти
Міністерства освіти і науки України
інституту професійної освіти
Національної академії педагогічних наук
інституту професійних кваліфікацій
закладів професійно-технічної та фахової
передвищої освіти а також викладачі
нашого університету та університету
менеджменту освіти
а Хочу зазначити що ми відкриті до
співпраці і сьогодні у нас дуже велике
представництво широке якщо наші колеги
які сьогодні присутні на вебінарі
зацікавилися і Готові взяти участь у
роботі нашого комітету будь ласка Ми
відкриті ми Запрошуємо усіх до
співпраці які основні напрями діяльності
комітету насамперед це формування
переліку компетентностей які якими на
сьогодні мають володіти здобувачі вищої
освіти за спеціальністю 015 професійна
освіта опрацювання пропозицій щодо
оновлення та розробки нових освітніх
програм реалізація спільних закладів і
проєктів спрямованих на покращення
якості підготовки здобувачів організація
практики здобувачів вищої освіти участь
в екзаменаційних місіях з атестації
здобувачів Ну і безумовно що участь в
акредитаційних процедурах спочатку
заснування нашого комітета ми провели
чотири засідання одне з яких відбулося
офлайн 19 травня цього року і хочу
відразу зазначити що активності які ми
проводимо в аудиторіях в стінах
університету в стінах закладах
професійно-технічної освіти безумовно
вони є більш
ефективнішими оскільки дійсно можна
налагодити ефективну співпрацю виробити
конкретні рекомендації для покращення
підготовки здобувачів вищої освіти за
спеціальністю 0,15 професійна освіта а
також у продовж діяльності нашого
комітету ми провели опитування
стейкхолдерів і з окремими результатами
користуючись нагодою Хочу поділитися
оскільки на наш погляд вони є досить
важливими для удосконалення освітніх
програм підготовки здобувачів вищої
освіти за спеціальністю 0,15 професійна
освіта серед основних результатів
а варто зазначити що 83% респондентів
зазначили що запропонована освітня
професійна програма дозволяє забезпечити
успішну підготовку бакалаврів з
професійної освіти з поміж найбільш
значущих компетентностей Якими мають
володіти здобвачі це здатність вчитися і
і оволодівати сучасними знаннями
здатність виявляти ініціативу та
підприємливість здатність застосовувати
освітні теорії та методології у
педагогічній діяльності здатність
забезпечити формування у здобувачів
освіти мається на увазі закладів
професійно-технічної та фахової
передвищої освіти цінностей
громадянськості і демократії а також
здатність керувати навчальними
розвивальними
проєктами
наступна структура над започаткуванням і
організації Якої роботи роботи якої ми
активно працювали це коворкінговий центр
економічної та
бізнесо-освіти даний центр з одного боку
є платформою для співпраці та активної
взаємодії зі стейкхолдерами а також
робота його спрямована на розвиток у
здобувачів професійних і особистісних
компетентностей зокрема цифрових Із
залученням стехолдерів які ми реалізуємо
заходи зі стейкхолдерами та здобувачами
на базі коворкінгового центру це
різноманітні тренінги наукові
конференції обговорення змісту
освітньо-професійної програми
кваліфікаційних робіт організація
практики організація олімпіад а також
різноманітні
профорієнтаційні
активності серед заходів які ми
провели в стінах нашого воркінгого
центру Дозвольте мені презентувати
кілька таких цікавих заходів Перший
захід - це адаптаційний тренінг для
здобувачів спеціальності професійна
освіта спеціалізація економіка цей захід
ми ось нещодавно провели
27го вересня цілями такого тренінгу була
організація комфортного освітнього
середовища та налагодження співпраці між
здобувачами різних курсів і вкладачами
розвиток професійної іденти чності
здобувачів та формування позитивної
навчальної спрямованості та заохочення
здобувачів до участі в програмах
міжнародної академічної
мобільності наші студенти ділилися
власним досвідом навчальної діяльності
досвідом міжнародних стажувань а також
ділилися перспективами щодо розвитку
своєї професійної кар'єри зокрема окремі
наші здобувачі
також зазначили що планують власне
займатися викладаською діяльністю після
здобуття вищої
освіти ще один цікавий
тренінг результатами якого ми хочемо
поділитися
це тренінг який ми проводили власне для
представників професійного дорачого
комітету назва тренінгу програма
Європейського Союзу asмус плюс генеруємо
ідеї для професійної освіти цей тренінг
ми проводили 19 травня цього року під
час тренінгу учасники дізналися про
особливості програми asмус плюс
специфіку проєктів співпраці між
організаціями та інституціями цілі та
напрями проєктів з розбудови потенціалу
у сфері професійної освіти пріоритети
міжнародного та національного розвитку у
сфері професійної освіти критерії вибору
теми проєкту використання інструмента
дерево проблем для обґрунтування теми
проєкту на сьогодні ми знаємо що
Європейський союз в межах програми
еasмус плюс дає змогу
е представникам закладів
професійно-технічної професійної освіти
а також фахової передвищої освіти брати
участь у програмах еразмус ПС е є
спеціальний напрямок фінансування різних
проектів
і якщо представники в нас тут є
представники закладів е
професійно-технічної
АЕ фахової передвищої освіти якщо ви
зацікавилися взяти участь в таких
програмах але не знаєте з чого почати
Вам бракує певних знань і навиків то Ми
запрошуємо можемо в межах нашого проекту
погосте провести такі тренінги і на цих
тренінгах ви не лише е одержите певні
знання
із знання Щодо цієї програми а і
напрацюєте певні навички з чого починати
як складати проектну заявку як вибрати
тему проекту Як формувати проєктний
консорціум і низку інших
важливих компетентностей тож якщо ви
зацікавились можете звертатися до наших
колег з Міністерства освіти і науки або
ж на цьому слайді бачите мої контакти
можете безпосередньо звернутися до мене
ми ще раз повторюю відкриті до співпраці
в будь-яких формах будь ласка
звертайтеся будемо
раді
Дякую е дякую пані Світлано е Я
сподіваюсь колеги встигли записати ваші
контакти якщо ні ми обов'язково ними
поділимося е на вимогу І запрошую
представити досвід Національного
транспортного університету у
впровадженні механізмів партнерства і
стейкхолдерами у підготовці майбутніх
викладачів професійної освіти Наталію
бондарна казала що цещо е та пані Альоно
ми дуже раді вас чути виключть будь
ласка звук Дякую тому Наталія Бондар
Доктор економічних наук професор кафедри
економіки національного трасполого
університету запрошую до слова добрий
день шановні колеги теж щиро рада вітати
всіх учасників вебінару і щиро вдячна
колегам з Міністерства освіти
директорату за те що вони організували
таку дійсно корисну подію для того щоб
ми обмінялися думками представили свої
результати досвідом обмінялися і знайшли
в майбутньому з партнерів для подальшого
покращення підготовки викладачів саме
для закладів професійної освіти е
Дозвольте представити вам е наш досвід
досвід Національного транспортного
університету у
підготовці майбутніх викладачів для
професійної освіти Справа в тому що
Національний транспортний університет
має таку специфіку більш технічного
напрямку і викладачі майбутні яких ми
готуємо
це вони мають таку бінарну освіту Вони
мають технічну освіту і мають технічну
освіту педагогічну якщо ми
говоримо На самому початку проекту було
розроблена дорожня карта і кожен заклад
подивився учасник проекту подивився свої
сильні СТО ни і питання які б хотілося б
вирішити якісь проблемні питання
Національний транспортний університет на
підставі отриманих результатів було
сформовано таку концепцію розвитку
системи підготовки педагогів професійної
освіти навчання в національному
транспортному університеті на основі
партнерства
ця концепція фактично дозволила нам
систематизувати ті завдання покроково як
ми їх будемо вирішувати
і на її пставі ми створили такий теж
дорадчий орган який називається Комітет
з підтримки забезпечення якості та
розвитку підготовки педагогів
професійної освіти і навчання в
національному транспортному університеті
до складу цього комітету увійшли у нас
як я казала підготовка вона така трошки
не не проста не одна кафедра випускає
цих фахівців у нас є кафедра філософії
педагогіки є багато технічних кафедр
наприклад технічної експлуатації та
автосервісу
виробництва кафедри будівельної механіки
і так далі тость є потреба в залучені
всіх випускових кафедр до складу цього
комітету ввійшли Гарант програми увійшли
завідувачі випускових кафедр увійшли
здобувачі освіти і ми запросили наших
стейкхолдерів це представники з
федерації роботодавців це були
представники і є представники з наших
структурних підрозділів і і представники
закладів професійної освіти в нас уже
відбулося декілька таких засідань ми
обговорювали Ну пізніше я розкажу
зустанюсь окремо Ми хочемо представити
вам в такому розрізі як ми співпрацюємо
з нашими
стейкхолдерами перше - це з точки зору
освітнього процесу друге сконкретизувати
напрямки які ми виокремили для себе в
співпраці з зі стейкхолдерами і теж
виокремити рівні співпраці зі
стейкхолдерами якщо ми гово говоримо про
освітній процес підготовки то ми
безпосередньо залучаємо наших
стекхолдерів до розробки освітніх
програм Справа в тому що всі проекти
освітніх програм розміщуються на сайті
університету і є можливість Ми
звертаємося з пропозиціями переглянути
доповнити отримаємо рецензії використо
Запрошуємо їх на обговорення засідань
які проходяться на засідання кафедри ми
впроваджуємо сучасні методики навчання
нам дуже корисна була участь в проекті
ми дуже вдячні всім організаторам тому
що було багато різноманітних тренінгів
на розвиток педагогічної майстерності і
46 викладачів саме з нашого університету
пройшли ці тренінги і ми дуже вважаємо
що Ну вони були для нас дуже корисним
досвідом ми активно залучали наших
партнерів закладів професійної освіти
долучатися до тих тренінгів і ми бачили
що дуже багато з них пройшли ці тренінги
отримали сертифікати і успішно
використовують набуті навички в роботі
Ми отримали сучасне обладнання е дуже
корисно в нас створено сьогодні
присутній наш представник завідувач
кафедри іноземної філології перекладу ми
створили спеціальний лінгвістичний
кабінет для того щоб здобувачі освіти
професійної освіти
е розвивали свої іншомовні
компетентності це дуже важливо в
сучасних умовах коли відкриті кордони і
коли ми можемо спокійно обмінюватися
досвідом з представниками інших країн в
нас розвинута далі більш вдосконалена
база кафедри філософії педагогіки
кафедри технічної експлуатації та
автомобільного транспорту розроблені
методичні вказівки от для технічних
спеціальностей обладнання яке Ми
отримали викладачі розробили спеціальні
методичні вказівки як використовувати Це
обладнання і обов'язково У нас є
зворотній зв'язок зі здобувачами освіти
з
викладачами З нашими стейкхолдерами з
випускниками Вони часто залучаються до
наших конференцій до співпраці з щодо
покращення освітніх
програм що стосується напрямків
співпраці це розширення баз практики у
нас створюється філії кафедри на
підприємстві залучаються викладачі
закладів професійної освіти до освітнь
процесу в нас коли була пам'ятаєте
пандемія і не було можливості реально
приходити практику вживу на е
підприємствах на закладах професійної
освіти е Ми дуже вдячні нашим партнерам
нашим структурного підрозділу це
Барський наш коледж який в онлайні
проводив майстер-класи для наших
студентів і вони задоволенням не тільки
студенти всі викладачі хто міг долучався
всі слухали З задоволенням ці
майстер-класи
Ми з зі сторони Національного
транспортного університету розроблені
програми для підвищення кваліфікації
викладачів саме закладів професійної
технічної освіти і ми проводимо спільні
науково науково-практичні конференції
тренінги разом з нашими партнерськими
закладами було проведено міжнародна
конференція іноваційні
рішення освіті науці і практиці далі у
нас рівень ми розглядаємо співпрацю на
рівні інституційному коли ми
співпрацюємо з викладачами з добувачами
освіти ми дійсно враховуємо думки їх
побажання щодо як вони бачать е освітній
процес і як його покращати на місцевому
рівні Ми співпрацюємо з закладами
професійної освіти Київської області Але
ми хочемо виходити і на області інші
області України Це було б дуже корисно
тому що фахівці в галузі на спеціаль
спеціалізація транспорт такі фахівці
потрібні Я думаю більш багатьом закладам
професійної освіти Ми співпрацюємо з
університетами завдяки нашому проекту ми
скажімо створили такий консорціум який
підтримує один одного і ми співпрацюємо
з закладами з університетами які готують
фахівців за спеціальністю професійна
освіта ми вдячні що налагоджена у нас
така тісна гарна праця з міністерством
освіти з федерацію роботодавців
транспорту України які дуже корисні
дають нам поради як вдосконалювати які
потреби є на ринку і національним
агентством кваліфікації і дуже вяч далі
дуже вдячні нашим партнерським
університетам
європейським якщо ми говоримо про
освітній процес у нас вже також
були чотири теж чотири засідання
комітету з підтримки забезпечення
якіскості та розвитку підготовки
педагогів професійної освіти в НТУ до
цих засідань ці засідання у нас завжди
приходять в розширеному форматі це
корисно тому що ми чуємо думку тих
безпосередньо людей які отримують наших
випускників на роботу і враховуємо їх
побажання тут ви бачите коротко те що я
говорила про те що А ще є таке такі
нюанси у нас збільшено обсяг практичної
підго ки до 25 кредитів це на рівні
бакалаврата
і педагогічна практика з них становить
15 кредитів ми вважаємо що це дуже
такий потужна зміна це яка відбулася під
час участі університету в проекті І це
ще простимульовано новими стандартами
які були про проведені проваджені
Міністерство
напрямки співпраці вони я казала вони
проходять у вигляді відкритих занять е-е
залучаються стейкхолдери до атестації
випускників за спеціальністю професійна
освіта створюються навчальні центри
ефірії капсер на виробництві у нас є
спільні такки центр НТУ scніia там де ее
підприємство постійно надає освітні о
самі останні моделі автомобілів і
здобивачі на них набувають своїх
практичних навичок те ж саме стосується
фірми GCB яка дає механізми будівельної
техніки так само наші здобувачі
отримують знання і в цій галузі ми
проводимо залучення залучаємо
стекхолдерів для до опитувань є на
сайтіту анкети і ми дуже вдячні якщо
наші стейкхолдери залучаються до нашої
такої співпраці і співпраця ще полягає в
тому що в нас розширюються бази практики
у нас вже укладено дев'ять угод і я
дуже-дуже ми сподіваємося що цих угод
буде більше про нашу співпрацю якщо ми
говоримо про співпрацю на інституційному
рівні ви бачите що ми сприяємо
підвищенню кваліфікації нашим викладачам
і ее залучаємо здобувачів викладачів
здобувачів до конференцій до академічної
мобільності вони даються їм можливості
створено в університеті
науково-педагогічний студентський гурток
кредоo опікується єм кафедра
філософії педагогіки вони там ро дійсно
такі суттєві проблеми
розглядають щорічно у нас йде опитування
як викладачів так і здобивачів освіти
щодо того чи задоволені вони якісті
отримуваних послуг якщо ми говоримо про
співпрацю на місцевому рівні у нас є
співпраця із закладами професійної
освіти щодо організації практики і
залучення до освітніх програм розробки
є працевлаштування випускників в
Київський Палац дітей та юнацтва він
поряд з нами і дуже багато студентів вже
будучи студентами вже Там працюють в
різноманітних технічних грутках і
розвивають свої педагогічні навички і
працюють наші випускники ще й в якості
тренерів на в відділах сервісу на
автосервісних і автотредінгових
компаніях на галузевому рівні я казала у
нас проводяться от
взимку проводився у нас такий семінар
між
університетами був Харківський
університет наш
поважний і національний економічний
університет і ми разом обговорювали саме
проблеми практики як проходить практика
змістовне
обговорення цих видів практики Тобто Це
дійсно обмін був досвідом обмін донками
І дійсно корис ми цього отримаємо Ну і
співпраця на національному міжнародному
рівні Ми дуже вдячні всім хто нас
підтримує і дуже вдячні що ми попали в
цей проект і отримали дійсно велику
користь для нашого університету і
заохочуємо всіх хто має можливість
бажання так само брати участь в таких
проектах тому що це неоцінений досвід
це зв'язки це можливості комунікувати і
розвивати
свої здатності в плані професійному
дуже-дуже вдячна всім за
увагу якщо є питаннякуку Дякуємо пані
наталь і запрошую Дениса Коваленка
доктора педагогічних наук професора
ректора Української
інженерно-педагогічної Академії
презентувати досягнення і проблеми
підготовки викладачів професійної освіти
на засадах партнерства в українській
інженерно-педагогічній академії
дякую пані
бачимо да до чутно мене чутно так так
чую
так Доброго дня шановні присутні Доброго
дня шановна пані Ірина Дякую вам за
можливість виступити на цьому вебінарі
та розповісти про заходи які ми
проводимо в нашій українськой
інженерно-педагічної академії
український інженерно-педагогічній
академії задля підвищення якості системи
підготовки викладачів закладів
професійної освіти наша українська
інженерна педагогічна академія - це
єдиний в Україні заклад вищої освіти що
саме спеціалізується на підготовці
кадрів для системи професійної освіти за
спеціальністю професійна освіта за
спеціалізаціями
[музика]
А про це можна казати виходячи хоча б з
того що 60% ліцензованого обсягу нашого
навчального закладу складає саме
спеціальність професійна освіта на
сьогодні в нашому навчальному закладі
реалізується 35 освітніх програм на всіх
рівнях вищої освіти які охоплюють всі
дев'ять спеціалізацій За якими в Україні
здійснюється Підготовка фахівців з
розміщенням державного
замовлення є деякі пріоритети нашого
навчального закладу тут вони на слайди
щодо розвитку спеціальності профе ійна
освіта а Дозвольте зупинитися на деяких
з них дуже стисло щоб не гайти часу
по-перше щодо формування контингенту
студентів саме мотивованих до роботи в
закладах професійної освіти то в нашому
закладів впроваджена інноваційна система
профорієнтаційної роботи е яка
передбачає формування бази потенційних
абітурієнтів саме мотивованих до роботи
в системі закладах професійної освіти
за допомогою мобільного зв'язку в нас
створений на бажі нашого закладу так
званий кол-центр фахівці якого у
телефонному режимі
популяризують професійну
е професію викладача системи професійної
освіти відповідають на ті питання які
виникають і знаходять саме мотивованих
студентів до роботи в системі закладів
професійної освіти певним чином
побудована робота нашої приймальної
комісії яка незважаючи на те в якій
складній ситуації опинилася наша держава
і наше місто зокрема ее работає всеш
таки в офлайн-режимі е треба сказати що
це не тільки наш заклад а багато комісій
але наша робота в теж в офлайн-режимі і
фахівці відповідають на всі питання що
виникають у вступників та та допомагають
при цьому а
ця робота привела до певних результатів
і в
22-му-23му році кількість вступників на
спеціальність професійна освіта завдяки
цієї роботи збільшилось на
32% щодо партнерства із закладами
професійної освіти то Українська
інженерно-педична академія є членами
проекту ерасмус плюс в рамках цього
проекту було обладнано п'ять аудиторій
комп'ютерною цифровою професійною
технікою яка незважаючи все ж таки на ту
ситуацію яка свідками якої ми на жаль з
вами є починаючи з 24 лютого Минулого
року Все ж таки це обладнання збереглося
як тільки буде
можливість працювати в
офлайн-режимі вона буде використана під
час навчального процесу щодо залучення
стейкхолдерів з числа найкращих
працівників системи професійної освіти
до освітнього процесу та виховання
студентів то до складу наглядової ради
нашого навчального закладу було введено
директорів закладів та керівників
крупних підприємств е ми постійно
залучаємо стейкхолдерів до роботи з
удосконале удосконалення змісту
освітньої та навчальнометодичної
документації залучаємо працівників
закладів системи професійної освіти у
якості керівників практик студентів
включаємо працівників закладів системи
професійної освіти до складу комісій які
приймають атестаційні
екзамени на базі нашої академії постійно
продовжує проходити підвищення
кваліфікації та стажування викладачів та
майстрів закладів системи професійної
освіти курсні підвищення кваліфікації
семінари круглі столи майстер-класи
лекції конференції тренінги вебінари все
це проходить на базі нашої академії
також ось починаючи з 2019 року по 23-й
рік на баши нашої академії кожного року
не менш ніж
225 викладачів проходять підвищення
кваліфікації от До речі в
22му-23 році 276 викладачів пройшли
курсні підвищення кваліфікації отримали
відповідні сертифікати Звертаю увагу що
121 з них є викладачами закладів
професійної освіти
88 майстри виробничого навчання закладів
професійної освіти е у нас проходять
школи педагогічної майстерності
стратегічні сесії науково-методичні
вебінари Ну то інші заклади які теж
проведення яких ми вважаємо можливими і
е-е в цьому напряму Ми теж робимо певну
роботу е постійно
підтримуємо контакт з випускниками
нашого навчального закладу ее надаємо
допомогу у у відновленій роботі закладом
освіти у воєнний та повоєнний час От
наприклад була проведена зустріч із
управлінням освіти до окупованого
ізюмського району їм була надана правова
методична психологічна організаційна
допомога на базі нашого навчального
закладу до речі розміщено керівництво
куп'янського регіонального центру
професійної
освіти в нашому навчальному закладі
створений так зване це теж певна
інновація єдиний учнівський студентський
простір та середовище між студентами
нашого навчального закладу та учнями
закладів професійної освіти тобто на
базі нашого закладу відкрито новий
студентський простір е стаді ковоorking
Де
е-е на території е української
інженерної педагічної академії ее
з'явилася можливість Ну так би мовити
взаємодії між між учнями
професійнонавчальних професійних
навчальних закладів та
студентами вищих навчальних закладів а
саме уєпа Ну для так би мовити розкриття
їх потенціалу
це теж
дуже велика дуже велике досягнення вони
можуть спілкуватися обмінюватись
досвідом та як сказав я розвивати свій
потенціал щодо підготовки сучасних
фахівців за спеціальністю профе на
освіта відповідно звісно до вимог
сьогодення то нами було проведено певне
анкетування результатами якого були
виявлені нові вимоги до викладача Які
звісно потребують додаткових умінь Ну то
робота з різновіковою аудиторією
розуміння психологічних особливостей
роботи з людьми у воєнний та повоєнний
час швидке застосування на втніх
технологій та інші З цією метою були
проведені певні інновації щодо
вдосконалення змісту освітніх програм
були внесені зміни у загальну
педагогічну психологічну фахову
складову були внесені певні інновації
щодо вдосконалення засобів навчання
застосування інформаційних
цервів інформаційних
сервісів були внесені певні інновації
щодо
інформаційно комунікаційних технологій
для викладачів професійної освіти в
межах саме підвищення кваліфікації але
на жаль на теперішній час все ж таки
залишилися деякі проблеми і цими
проблемами ну насамперед є те що не всі
випускники спеціальності професійна
освіта як ви самі І знаєте
працевлаштовуються До закладів системи
ее професійної
освіти як спосіб вирішення цього питання
ми вважаємо створення системи
профрієнтаційни професійної орієнтації
та кар'єрного консультування молоді та
дорослих щодо привабливості професії
викладача системи професійної освіти тут
ее з цього приводу на базі нашого
навчального закладу був створений так
званий центр креативності та кар'єрного
росту він почав роботу Ну Сподіваємось
що він зараз вже працює Сподіваємось що
це теж принесе в цьому напряму певні
результати
А я так щоб не гаяти часу дуже стисло ее
по кожному слайду так би мовити
поверхово пройшовся але ця презентація
якщо буде запотрібна буде
викладена на сайті і всі бажаючі зможуть
з нею ознайомитись Ще раз дякую за увагу
Дякую за те що надали можливість
виступити На сьогоднішньому нашому
вебінарі Дякую пане Денисе і хотіла б
зауважити що не тільки ця
презентація буде викладена на YouTube
каналі Міністерства освіти і науки
України але й презентації всіх е
учасників цього вебінару і перш ніж
перейти до останнього нашого
е кейсу е підготовки викладачої
професійної освіти Я б хотіла зазначити
що прошу учасників у разі виникнення
запитань писати їх в чат і ми ее по
завершенню постараємося відповісти на
них і запрошую до слова Валентину
радкевич доктора педагогічних наук
професора директора інституту
професійної освіти Національної академії
педагогічних наук України презентувати
платформу створеною інститутом
партнерський простір
015 Доброго дня шановні колеги наші
партнери по консорціуму і Дорогі наші
освітяни Ну мабуть не дотково наш проект
напередодні такого величного свята дня
працівника
освіти ініціює наші результати які
будуть послуговуватися у розвитку і
вищої і професійної і фахової передвищої
освіти інститут професійної освіти взяв
найактивнішу участь у проекті і має два
таких важливих національного рівня
результати перший результат - це був наш
професійний стандарт педагогпрофесійного
навчання який сьогодні оновлений і він
виставлений на платформі національного
агентства кваліфікацій і ми чекаємо що
хтось зініціює розроблення відповідно до
нового стандарту новий освітній стандарт
тому що не збігаються і функції і
компетентності і професійний заявляє
нові уже компетентності а освітній
стандарт ще продовжує застосовуватися і
готувати педагогів викладачів
професійної освіти за старими освітніми
програмами і безумовно Це комунікаційна
платформа партнерський простір 015 це
унікальна платформа Я вважаю Вона має
надзвичайно важливе значення і велике
майбутнє чому Ну насамперед це платформа
яка створена для
комунікації осві ринку освітніх послуг і
ринку праці і її важлива ще роль велика
у тому що вона
спрямована на розвиток усіх педагогів в
тому числі і викладачів і майстрів
виробничого навчання і керівників і
методистів тобто кожен педагог зможе на
цій платформі знайти для себе унікальну
інформацію яка буде сприяти
вдосконаленню його педагогічної
діяльності і безумовно ця платформа дає
нам змогу налагодити от сьогодні
говорила пані Ірина про комунікацію от
саме комунікацію з ринком праці
стейкхолдерами з громадськими
організаціями які сьогодні беруть
найактивнішу участь у модернізації
освіти на всіх
рівнях що собою являє ця платформа Ми
всі з вами знаємо що вона по-перше і
лічна Ну і безумовно безкоштовна ми
єдине що зробили це купили хостинг
купили домене ім'я і нашими невеликими
зусиллями нашого інституту тому що в нас
невеликий колектив але ми Стараємося
допомогти кожному Хто хоче взяти участь
у цій платформі і зараз і допомагаємо
приєднатися і навіть допомагаємо
виставити певну інформацію і да і надалі
будемо сприяти цьому це дуже гнучка
платформа і це система яка дає змогу без
усіляких знань програмування тобто тут
не потрібні ніякі знання тим хто хоче
брати участь в цій платформі без знань
програмування ще раз повторюю створювати
сторінки і наповнювати їх любим текстом
і любими
відеоповідомленнями і любими
гіперпосиланнями і фотографіями тобто
тут можна створювати такий контент який
є сьогодні актуальним в закладі освіти і
який Можливо потім згодом буде
актуальним для проведення заходів там чи
виставлення
новин платформа складається якщо ви
побачите на са на цій на цьому слайді із
семи сторінок ну головна сторінка вона
повністю от викладає що собою являє
сторінка от головна сторінка я вам
показую вона представлена нашими що
головна сторінка ще під'єднана календар
от заходів де ми виставляємо якщо
вводимо якусь захід або потім новина
відбувається відповідно до цього заходу
то тут представлено коли має відбутися
той чи
інший захід далі е сторінка має має дуже
важливе значення сторінка викладача
Наприклад якщо ми включаємо цю сторінку
то ви бачите що що
відбувається ця сторінка розподіляється
ще на певні От такі сторінки як гранти
майстер-класи стажування курси
підвищення кваліфікації проекти тренінги
тобто тут викладачі знаходять собі най
таку актуальнішу програму от ми
спеціально на слайді представили які
можуть бути курси підвищення
кваліфікації які зараз проводяться і на
які можна подати Грант
От і відповідно Які заходи будуть
проводитися згодом для того щоб
викладачі або керівники або майстри
виробничого навчання взяли участь у цих
чи інших заходах наступна сторінка наша
студентам безумовно що це теж дуже
актуальна сторінка тому що ми хотіли
показати для студентів а навіть і для і
для абітурієнтів які можуть потім згодом
стати студентами які сьогодні актуальні
освітньо-професійні програми в тих чи
інших закладах вищої освіти безумовно що
поки що тут у нас представлені заклади
які здійснюють підготовку педагогів
професійної освіти Але я думаю що згодом
Якщо ця платформа у нас вона так
розкрутиться і буде дуже популярною то
тут може любий заклад вищої освіти
університет представляти свою інформацію
свої освітнь професійні програми і тим
самим рекламувати свій заклад і по суті
це і є професійна орієнтація тому що ми
можемо це використовувати для
популяризації тих чи інших
спеціалізацій студентам теж пропонується
сторінка гранти е дуже важливою є
сторінка практика ми сьогодні маємо
велику проблему коли наприклад наші
студенти Не можуть знайти практику або
їхні керівники так от саме ця сторінка
дає змогу нам зробити запит на ту чи
іншу установу чи той чи інший заклад бо
в принципі наші студенти-педагоги Вони
шукають собі практику в закладах вищої
освіти наприклад в інститутах
науково-дослідних Вони шукають собі е
практики то тут вони можуть робити
заявки на практику А ми як е суб'єкти
надання практики можемо теж виставляти
пропозиції що ми можемо брати на
практику цих студентів тобто тут іде вже
комунікація двох сторін Е тут дуже
цікавою є сторінка робота що на на цій
сторінці студенти можуть собі
здійснювати пошук роботи і от саме на
цій сторінці ми будемо ініціювати щоб
роботодавці в тому числі заклади
професійної фахової передвищої освіти і
навіть на виробництві то бо там потрібні
теж тренери педагоги
щоб вони виставляли пропозиції для
пошуку тих претендентів на робочі місця
які в них є або в закладах освіти або на
підприємствах студентам теж Ми
пропонуємо самі різноманітні інформацію
про проекти А також про
тренінги унікальною є теж сторінка яка
стосується заходів Я вже дещо говор
говорила про заходи але тут ми
акцентуємо ті заходи і які потім
відображаються знову ж в календарі які
можуть бути згодом проведені
е різними закладами і до яких можуть
доєднатися партнери або учасники які
розміщені на цій платформі от Ну і
безумовно що кожен захід Він має свою
певну таку пропозицію щодо
зареєструватися і ее ми тоді вже е-е
маємо змогу брати участь у цих заходах
е-е актуальною є сторінка партнери от
щодо партнерів Шановні колеги е ми дуже
проводили велику роботу популяризації
платформи і популяризації щоб
приєднувалося більше партнерів От і
виставляли про себе
інформацію і я хочу по сказати вам що
там де партнери і де виставлені значки і
ваші
інформація от вони отак представлені
Тому що тут є інформація про вашу
установу про ваш заклад про ваші напрями
діяльності
але останнім часом почало дуже багато
безумовно приєднуватися закладів освіти
Але вони просто подумали що для них
тільки зареєструватися на платформі щоб
там висіла їх назва закладу і все і
таких сторінок у нас дуже багато з
партнерами таких от ви бачите отут внизу
партнери там де у нас
е-е по тільки написано заклад назва а
ніякої інформації немає тому просимо тих
наших партнерів які
приєдналися вони за підписали меморандум
про взаємодію на цій платформі
заповнювати інформацію на своїй сторінці
як партнера і щоб ми
бачили який у вас профіль які ви
програми
реалізовуєте які у вас
перспективи щоб теж якщо захоче потім
згодом зайти любий абітурієнт то він
просто буде знати пройде по цих
сторінках і подивиться що Йому цікаво і
куди би він міг би піти потім навчатися
у нас є дуже цікава сторінка асоціація
асоціація і дуже Дуже дякую нашій
українській інженерно-педогогічній
академії за ініціювання цієї асоціації
тому що ми як члени консорціуму зразу
увійшли до цієї асоціації але вона
відкрита для кожного закладу освіти для
кожного взагалі суб'єкта і ринку праці і
ринку освітніх послуг і громадські
організації вона відкрита і ми би
просили всіх От хто сьогодні слухає нас
приєднатися до цієї
асоціації тому що ця асоціація теж має
дуже великі
перспективи і участі в міжнародних
проектах і участі у вітчизняних проектах
тобто самі-самі
різноманітні напрями діяльності і
взаємодії в рамках цієї
асоціації наступна У нас теж цікава
сторінка
новини От новини Тут взагалі дуже
є можливість
показати активність кожного закладу от
які він проводить заходи от знову ж вона
пов'язана з заходами які ми можемо
висвітлювати і не тільки про заходи там
відбувається якась подія в закладі ми
висвітлюємо в новинах але тільки за тих
умов якщо заклади подали цю новину
безумовно що найбільше новин наших тому
що ми як інститут ми дублюємо дещо ми
дублюємо із свого сайту ми зразу її
розповсюджуємо цю інформацію і Facebook
і на платформу 015 і я би радила всім
нашим партнерам і нашим колегам нашим
освіттянам теж дублювати ту інформацію
яку яка виставляється у вас на сайті
зразу її дублюйте на 015 платформу в
Фейсбуке і будьде бо це є реклама вашого
закладу е-е далі
безумовно що ее хочу сказати що інститут
і ви наші партнери з консорціуму брали
активну участь у підготовці
адміністраторів цієї платформи ми для
цього розробили методичні рекомендації
виставили їх на головній сторінці на
слайдері е платформи кожен раз можна
зайти подивитися і ее ну якби
актуалізувати як працює ця платформа
окрім того наш доктор професор заступник
з наукової роботи Микола Анатолійович
пригодій зробив унікальну дорожную карту
уже ніхто не може сказати що він не
зрозуміє як працювати або заповнювати
інформацію на цій платформі Там просто
взагалі так розписано до деталей що
навіть мабуть уч учень першого класу
зрозуміє Яку кнопку нажати і як далі
рухатися по тій дорожній карті на
платформі
е інтерфейс постійно удосконалюється ми
постійно на зв'язку з розробниками
платформи Слава Богу що вони нам
допомагають не не відмовляють і якщо від
вас є якісь пропозиції ми завжди
реагуємо і продовжуємо вдосконалювати цю
платформу і забезпечувати такий от
гнучкий доступ до різних сторінок і до
переходу з різних сторінок і на головну
сторінку і між
сторінками ми сказали про те що нами
підготовлено уже кілька спочатку було
чотири тренера Зараз ми підготовили
50 пройшли навчання роботи на платформі
дуже багато наших працівників брало
участь у цьому тобто Зараз ми маємо уже
150 закладів підключилися до
веб-платформи сподіваємося що за
підтримки нашого директорату професійної
освіти які
актуалізували підключення до цієї
платформи для закладів освіти у нас буде
ще більше підключень і ми будемо їх
мотивувати щоб вони виставляли ще і свою
інформацію і таким чином ми зможемо
потім популяризувати нашу освіту і наш
проект і результати нашого вашої нашої
взаємодії Дякую за увагу Дуже дякую всім
за роботу за участь і Сподіваюсь на
подальшу нашу взаємодію на цій платформі
Дякую за
увагу Дякую Валентину олександрівну
Дякую усім спікерам нашого вебінару і
бачу в чаті запитання з приводу
матеріалів цього вебінару та запису і як
уже ми відповідали запис буде на нашій
сторінці YouTube Міністерства освіти а
також інформація про всі активності
проекту погоста є на офіційній сторінці
погоста Запрошуємо до перегляду також
для активної реєстрації на партнерському
просторі 015 Разом до перемоги Дякую
колеги за ваш приділений час і
сподіваюсь До наступних
зустрічей Дякуємо організатор дяку до
побачення до побачення Дякуємо
до